si vous appelez parti populiste vous
imaginez on voit là une erreur voilà une
erreur gigantesque énorme
vous imaginez terre que tout pour
désigner le mal enfin ce qu'on considère
comme le mâle pour mobiliser contre le
mal
on le comment le qualifie comment
qualifie communiste on prend le mot où
il ya le mot peuple dans l'est mais qui
pourraient pas souhaité tard il faut pas
rêver mieux
le mot il ya le mot peuple les gens ils
entendent populaire populiste ils
entendent populaire médicaux assez mal
du populaire franchement c'est ma à peu
en dise nationaux cd nationaux
populistes adéquat alors je suis
patriote est populaire mais c'est très
bien et c'est alors sans compter que
quand vous dites
mélenchon et populiste le pen et
populiste boucher populiste chavez et
populiste castro et mobile ça veut dire
quoi quand tout le monde peut être
peuple et à mesure or cette utilisation
paranoïaque quasiment de ce mot
populiste pour désigner tout ce dont on
veut pas mais ça a été une erreur mais
gigantesque elle est la preuve la preuve
c'est que c'était disqualifiant
normalement on l'avait pour disqualifier
mais aujourd'hui ce réclament ils disent
nous sommes populistes sont compris
[Musique]